ces ventes là ça me rappelle que vous
poser bien des questions et hier plus
vient de contre valeurs bien compris et
derrière que si l'on voulait vous rendre
hommage on a un reportage sur les grands
moments de votre carrière écouter ces
gentilles je regarde ça
[Musique]
dans de 30 et ce soir on apprend au lac
monsieur bourassa nouvelle vie et au
plaisir de se retrouver peut-être dans
la grille horaire de riche de quelque
part entre une rediffusion des pierres
et feux de forêt canadienne qu'un petit
dixième piscine maintenant alors
rejoindre l'animatrice de l'émission le
monde ce matin christine fournier
bonjour christine mans jean pascal le
moi je me trouve devant la régie de
production
en fait derrière ces titres c'est là que
travaille notre réalisateur et son
équipe moins six enfants sont morts à la
suite d'une violente explosion qui a
presque complètement détruit un immeuble
fédéral à oklahoma city dans le centre
des états unis
on est au printemps 95 ya jamais eu des
missions spéciales non préparés à rdi et
leur survie les événements d'oklahoma
s'est vraiment saisissant alors pendant
cette heure je suis sur l'adrénaline je
décris je décris je décris on va avec
des intervenants le gouverneur de l'état
et le cher de l'heure à 10 ans ouf on a
bien travaillé quand même même si on
n'avait pas les moyens parce qu'il y
avait aucune équipe des missions
spéciales qui était dans une tragédie
qui vient de survenir dans la ville de
new york on voit le deuxième appareil
qui va aller coucher
la deuxième tours du world trade center
et pendant que les caméras justement
nous montrait le feu qui a suivi
justement l'explosion dans l'une des
tours on voit le deuxième appareil qui
va les toucher
la deuxième tours du world trade center
vous voyez alors ce qui fait dire
justement commentateurs américains qu'il
s'agit là d'un attentat dans la période
la plus cruciale de ces tristes
événements c'est à dire premier avion
deuxième avion écroulement du premier
immeuble écroulement du deuxième
immeuble et là on essaie d'écrire et on
n'en crois pas mes yeux
on s'imagine que c'est quasiment de la
science fiction
alors notre match les élus se poursuit
cinq fédéral aujourd'hui avec monsieur
blé rodriguez paquet et mulcair on va
parler d'achat d'avions militaires f 35
ans l'industrie aérospatiale québécoise
beau profitera tomber l'eau et qu'est ce
qu'on doit s'arrêter puisque l'émission
se termine alors on a hâte de voir quel
est ce je vous souhaite une bonne fête
soit belle dans la sérénité voilà merci
beaucoup à tous les cas au revoir c'est
ce matin vers 10 heures aura lieu le
tout premier vol de la cseries de
bombardier
donc j'en parle tout de suite avec
gérald fillion qui se trouve là bas un
événement attendu depuis longtemps pour
dire gerald absolument parce que ça a
été reporté au fil du temps à plusieurs
reprises s'est fait plus d'une décennie
qu'on parle de la cci ce qu'on développe
la 6 e richard christine fournier moi
qui te passe est immortel à l'antenne
parce que pas si longtemps à tqs je te
voyais à l'antenne je t'ai vue bien sûr
dans plusieurs rôles toujours à
l'animation
ici à radio canada et ailleurs alors je
pense que tu t'en vas roulé roulé roulé
faire beaucoup beaucoup de vélo à la
rencontre des deux belles personnes et
de belles régions de beau pays
ç'a toujours été un immense plaisir de
travailler avec toi je garde le souvenir
d'une journaliste très curieuse des
enjeux économiques très intéressé je l'
ai toujours vu et entendu de ta part
alors vraiment ça a été un vrai beau
plaisir de travailler avec toi salue ce
jeudi matin 23 janvier restera très
clairement dans l'esprit des gens de
l'île verte et si christine fourni on va
mettre de côté notre émission sous la
loupe ce matin on va laisser toute la
place aux informations qui nous
parviennent de la petite municipalité
delvert dans le bas du fleuve où un
incendie monstre a ravagé une résidence
pour personnes âgées cette nuit
voilà nouvelles de dernière heure on se
rend tout de suite à ottawa on vient
d'apprendre qu'un soldat aurait été la
cible de tireurs ottawa les événements
se seraient produits au monument
commémoratif de guerre du canada de nick
qu'est ce qu'on s'est jusqu'à maintenant
bonds est par ailleurs alex on attend
maintenant des projections officielles
quant à la progression de la pandémie au
québec un engagement du gouvernement
lorsqu'on dit c'est qu'on va travailler
avec les experts dès qu'on aura des
chiffres crédibles a montré pour savoir
où on se dirige le camp sera le sommet
de la fameuse courbe en cuisine
alors comme ça c'est le moment de la
retraite j'ai été surpris de l'apprendre
comme j'imagine pas mal ont été surpris
aussi un réseau canada et je suis
convaincu même au québec et au canada
tu vas me manquer tu vas nous manquer
les converses qu'on faisait le matin
vont me manquer de toujours été un
modèle pour moi modèle de
professionnalisme
un professionnalisme toujours exemplaire
ta capacité de vulgariser le fait qu'un
livre est toujours comme ça 100% ce que
tu avais a livré tout ça voulait dire
beaucoup pour pas mal de monde dont moi
j'ai beaucoup appris toi d'abord parce
que quand j'étais plus jeune je te
regarde à la télévision mais aussi parce
que par exemple lorsque j'étais aussi
pour elle mais pour la première fois sur
un plateau là c'est toi qui
m'accompagnait c'est toi qui m'ont
partager des connaissances et il le fait
très bien je l' ai beaucoup apprécié et
donc aujourd'hui faute de pouvoir te
saluer en personne
je voulais quand même temps envoyé cette
vidéo là te dire que ce que tu as fait
est important je me souviendrai de ces
conversions qu'on ne fait pratiquement
tous les matins pendant quatre ans avant
de manquer ceux ci certains mais je
convaincu que pour toi c'est un autre
chapitre et que tu reprends mobilité
journée comme qu'il souhaite
je te souhaite tout le bonheur possible
parce que je sais que si ça va être
agréable aussi de penser à autre chose
donc j'espère pouvoir croiser dans un
futur pas trop éloigné des silos je
tenais à te remercier et à saluer salut
christine bonne chance
ottawa daniel le parlement lui sera à
nouveau convoqué cette fois pour
ratifier la subvention sans précédent
qui va exercer aux entreprises pour les
aider à traverser cette crise là voilà
retour des parlementaires à ottawa pour
se pencher là dessus c'est un programme
sans précédent que c'est une 71
milliards de dollars 71 milliards c'est
du jamais vu
chère christine ça fait tout drôle de
penser que je ne te verrai plus dans mon
téléviseur le matin et je verrai plus
ton sourire apparaître quelques secondes
avant comptia ce que j'entendrais plus
non plus ton petit rire tout charmant
quand le temps nous échanges prend une
tournure un peu plus légères d'origine à
toronto puis à ottawa aussi ou un peu
partout sur le terrain je me suis
promené un peu durant ma carrière mais
il y avait une chose qui était à peu
près certaine c'est que quel que soit
l'endroit où je me trouvais il y avait
souvent à l'autre bout de la petite
oreillette ta voix si douce et familière
pour guider nos conversations
tu m'as manqué ma chère même si en même
temps tu mérite bien un peu de temps à
toi je te souhaite une excellente
retraite beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
vélo et du plaisir à profusion à travers
tout ça jeudi gros bisous entre temps
c'est mon collègue patrice roy qu'il
vous attend pour le point de presse du
premier ministre que d'autres suivi de
celui de monsieur legault bana familles
de la trentaine et à demain mesdames
messieurs bonjour
chère christine je te souhaite une belle
retraite bon vin profites-en chat
christine 40 ans de carrière en
journalisme 25 ans à rdi toujours été
solide comme un roc en ondes
on te souhaite que cette retraite soit
le début d'une nouvelle aventure tout
aussi passionnante que celle qui
s'achève au nom de toute l'équipe du mic
en après midi
on te souhaite une très bonne route
christine alors qu'à 25 ans tuque lancer
dans l'aventuré d'info continue avec la
naissance d'eyrda y moi j'étais dans mon
salon en train de comprendre que c'était
ce que je voulais faire dans la vie
merci d'avoir défricher le chemin parce
qu'une grande partie de notre métier tu
sais ne s'apprend pas sur les bancs
d'école te regarder a été très formateur
alors merci d'avoir été en quelque sorte
une donnée essentielle
[Musique]
salut christine bonjour martin biron
dans ma voiture
ben ça vacances pour 27 ans d'amitié il
faut bien que je viens de souligner ça
avec toi ou est un gentil on s'est
rencontrés dans les escaliers de radio
canada on a vécu
tod 2 d'histoire de nouvelles on a vécu
aussi des voyages on a même vécu
ensemble pendant le verglas c'est te
souviens-tu que j'ai joué j'étais chez
toi pour jeu profitait du fait que tu
restais dans un rayon où il y avait de
l'électricité la wii
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses avec toi je
t'adore
mais ce que je reconnais le plus de ta
carrière c'est ton flegme ta capacité de
te retourner sur un dix cennes et ton
prochain sonnera l'heure de mon fait un
peu cliché le professionnalisme est avec
toi
on avait toujours l'impression d'avoir
un parachute de travailler avec des pros
avec des juniors avec des nouveaux et tu
as toujours été extrêmement accueillante
moi je sais une chose par exemple c'est
qu'on va se revoir bon bah oui
effectivement j'espère que oui il
faudrait pas en plus à vous de fait
partie de tous les gens extraordinaires
que j'ai rencontrés depuis depuis que je
fais ce métier-là quarante deux ans au
temps des invités sur le plateau que les
gens avec qui on travaille dans cette
extraordinaire j'ai vu ta soupe et
j'accepte merci au revoir merci dans